who among us hasn't wondered what
happens after our lives have come to
their inevitable ending and we play out
our final moments in the land of the
living the concept of what happens to us
after we've died has baffled scientists
and philosophers the world over for
almost as long as human civilization has
existed some out there already claim to
know the exact answer you probably
already know that the belief in the
existence of an afterlife is one held by
almost every single religion and culture
around the globe heaven hell valhalla
purgatory limbo
the world to come descriptions of the
afterlife and how to get sent there
often varies depending on the religion
or cultural group it is linked to but to
think in more general terms the concept
usually revolves around the soul leaving
the body after death and living forever
in eternal paradise that is of course
unless you've committed any deadly sins
during your lifetime if the myths are to
be believed these normally result in you
being sent down to spend eternity in
damnation and endless punishment instead
of paradise sadly there's no way to
prove if any of the various afterlifes
actually exist by their very nature
these afterlifes exist separate from the
real physical world that we live in
while we are still alive while we're
here on earth we can only observe what
we see happening to a body after death
and what we assume or believe the
afterlife might be like after all it's
not like any deceased person can tell us
what being dead is like well not under
the normal circumstances anyway with no
proof of the afterlife's existence we do
unfortunately get left with the bleak
and existentially terrifying assumption
that when we die there is nothing
waiting for us on the other side what if
there is no light at the end of the
tunnel no pearly gates
just
nothing forever but what if someone or
some mysterious group of persons already
knew the answer to what happened after
the end of all human life and what if
the answer was so much more horrifying
than we ever could have imagined so much
so that this shadowy cabal had already
tried to prevent the fate awaiting all
of us after we die
be warned we're about to delve into the
unsettling tale of something known as
project demeron and its connection to
something known as scp-3448
as the foundation categorizes it it is a
story about our fear of what comes next
beyond this mortal coil this is the
catalyst for the foundation uncovering
the most horrific secret in human
history a truth that should have stayed
buried warning we are about to unravel
the beginning of the end the end of what
you might be asking why the end of death
itself of course any outsider looking in
might think we're being a little bit
over dramatic here but we'll forgive you
for that mistake you can have that one
on us
at first glance to the untrained eye and
uninformed individual
scp-3448 might just seem like little
more than a magnetic resonance imaging
machine chances are you've seen these
big machines in medical dramas or maybe
you've even been placed inside one
during a stay at the hospital using
powerful magnets an mri machine aligns
all the protons in your body then the
machine generates a pulse of radio
frequency current to create a detailed
image of the inside of a patient's body
basically to put it in extremely
oversimplified terms it's a big camera
for looking at your internal organs now
don't forget to smile really show off
that pancreas it looks great at this
angle of course when dealing with
anomalies encountered by the scp
foundation few things are ever really
exactly as they first seem and in that
very same vein
scp-3448 is far more than just a
harmless piece of medical apparatus look
beyond the main bulk of the mri machine
and you'll start to notice that a few
unique modifications have been made to
the device for one the winding mass of
jumper cables connecting the machine to
its rudimentary upgrades namely the same
type of technology used in particle
accelerators along with a whole
collection of custom circuit boards for
another although you wouldn't know just
from looking at scp-3448
the contraption has also been through a
number of anomalous rituals seemingly
combining the technological with the
occult and spiritual but the question
remains
why what is this thing for exactly to
put it simply it's a hotline to the
great beyond
scp-3448 is a means of communication
with the world of the dead themselves
now we might be oversimplifying things
yet again there so let's take it from
the top project amarong was the name
given to those who developed scp-3448
that designation doesn't just refer to
the modified mri machine itself but also
the communication that said device was
capable of after the project amarong
team had finished their tinkering with
it you see nobody knows what happens to
us after we die because no one has ever
been able to experience being dead in
the real world and existing in the
afterlife at the same time but with
scp-3448
that problem just simply isn't an issue
anymore still with us so far okay here's
how the machine actually works a living
human is placed inside just like those
ordinary mri machines at your local
hospital however the difference here is
that the extra anomalous components of
scp-3448
the rituals the particle acceleration
and so on allow this person to enter a
unique state of being halfway between
life and death their bodily functions
are halted brought to a stop by the
machine however they are still able to
retain their consciousness and the
awareness that this allows for not quite
dead but not quite alive either sort of
an unalive state or a half-death if you
prefer or perhaps afterlife now while a
person is in this half death they will
have entered a conceptual state of being
this is referred to as scp-3448-a
an existence of pure consciousness while
physical form in this case the person's
body exists separately in the real world
the body now called
scp-3448-1 no longer houses a subject's
consciousness their essence not just
their mind but their thoughts and
personality if it helps to think of it
in theological terms you could even
think of it as their soul but while the
machine's function is all very
impressive and interesting what's the
actual point to it why spend so much
time trying to create a controlled
separation of consciousness from a dead
body what's project damarang for well
that's easy
scp-3448 is the primary tool intended to
complete the sole objective of project
damaron a mission to capture a dangerous
cognito hazard namely death itself to be
clear when we say death we don't mean
the grim reaper that skull phase
scythe-wielding embodiment of oblivion
chances are you can probably catch him
just by going out on halloween with a
big net but project damarang's goal was
to contain the actual process of death
the very concept that takes a living
conscious entity and makes it the
opposite you see when a living subject
is placed in
scp-3448 and their consciousness leaves
their brain it leaves behind some kind
of anomalous electrical energy signature
as you may already know if you can
remember back to high school biology
class the brain uses electrical impulses
to send signals all over the body
allowing your organs to function your
limbs to move and your muscles to
contract or relax what's strange is this
electrical activity seems to continue
within the brain of someone whose
consciousness has been separated from
their body by scp-3448
studying these signals the scp
foundation personnel working on project
amarong have inferred that these are
residual signals replicating how the
brain would react if the subject
introduced into the half-dead
scp-3448-1 state as if they were still
alive even though they have to be dead
in order to access that state in the
first place and now your brain is
probably such a mess of electrical
signals trying to keep up with all of
that that you might have actually
completely missed the part where we told
you that project damarang is actually a
foundation-backed project okay let's
have a speedy recap so far we have an
anomalously modified mri machine capable
of splitting the consciousness or soul
of a person after rendering them
clinically dead on top of that the
foundation themselves sanctioned the
project that created this device in an
effort to capture and contain death
itself but how did this come about who
among the scp foundation would want to
contain death so much to commission an
entire project dedicated to that goal
well who do we all know sitting above
the entire foundation overseeing
everything infamous for all having some
anomalous form of immortality and would
stand to gain from project tamarang
that's right the world championship
death dodgers the 05 council you see in
order to more fully understand why
project amarong was established and why
they built
scp-3448 we need to explain a little bit
about a different anomaly
scp-2718 we have another video on this
channel that goes into more detail about
that but to put it in a nutshell
scp-2718
is the horrible truth about what happens
to us after we die the o5 council first
learned of it when one of their own
05-11 full name roger sheldon died of a
stroke 05-11 was the only council member
to have refused to accept any of the
anomalous treatments or enhancements
that prevented the other o5s from dying
however the council chose to resurrect
him upon his return to the land of the
living roger sheldon told the other
overseers what he had learned about the
nature of the afterlife what lies beyond
this fleeting mortal coil waiting for us
after we die
roger had experienced firsthand that the
dead actually remain conscious after
their bodies have shut down all other
functions that meant that everyone every
person to have died over the course of
human history has remained aware of
everything that happened to them
afterward they can feel themselves
slowly decaying their bones and skin
withering buried under the cold wasting
away into nothingness day after day and
that's scp-2718
the painful truth that there is no
paradise no heaven no afterlife there is
just endless silent consciousness beyond
the end of every life this revelation is
what instigated the overseer council
specifically 05-4 to establish project
damarang it was learning the answer to
what happens next that spurred the
creation of scp-3448
the intention was by reading and
interacting with those residual
electrical signals in the brain that the
foundation could create a link a form of
two-way communication between them and
the living world and the subject
scp-3448-a
in their half-dead state using other
items anomalous technology connected to
the mri machine the foundation's
researchers could interpret the
electrical signals in
scp-3448-a's brain as images a
foundation agent by the name of anthony
michaels proved to be the only test
subject capable of using scp-3448
beyond the earliest tests on animal
specimens and we know what you're
thinking the foundation would normally
use d-class personnel for this sort of
test after all it's a machine that
renders you almost dead stopping all
bodily function the problem was project
amarong needed someone loyal to the
foundation and d-classes could hardly be
trusted to follow orders without the
threat of death think about it you
separate their consciousness from their
body and they don't care if you threaten
to kill them agent michaels served as
the scp-3448-a
component residing within the modified
mri machine held in a state between life
and death but something went wrong
something that would ultimately do more
harm than good the foundation had tried
in vain to contain death and in
tampering with forces well beyond their
own understanding may have accidentally
done something even worse
they neutralized it they killed
death and things only went downhill from
there now go check out evil monster
created by scp foundation
scp-2419 the laughing man and
scp-006 fountain of youth for more scps
that blurred the line between life and
death